it's the destiny of the human race
expressed in numbers and it's the reason
the empire will take us they're worried
you can predict the future they're
worried people believe i can and they
don't like the future i predict which is
what
hey guys pete here this will be my
breakdown for the first two episodes of
the first season of foundation the apple
tv plus adaptation of the classic sci-fi
series by isaac asimov they delivered
two long episodes that are dense and
especially in the first one there are a
lot of important details i put together
a fairly comprehensive recap which is
also long and so i added chapters in
case you're already familiar with the
story and you just want to skip to the
good stuff as a warning this video will
contain spoilers if you haven't watched
the first two episodes i will be talking
about the book series that the show is
based on without giving away any
spoilers for future plot points that
come from reading them with that out of
the way let's get into it if you've read
isaac asimov's foundation books watched
my intro videos or read any of the press
about the tv show then you know the
story spans a long period of time
if not there's a monologue from gail
dornick to open the series that sets it
up what's interesting here is that it
comes from the perspective of the future
she says that one day she'll learn the
name salvor hardin pober mallow and the
mule as she's talking viewers are
introduced to salvor the planet terminus
and the mysterious vault that hovers
above the ground there we see some local
kids try to approach it and get an
explanation from salvor who they refer
to as the warden that the vault is
warning them to stay away although it's
implied that she's not affected by the
null field it generates right off the
bat you get the idea that the story is
going to be big you're introduced to two
timelines and three planets in the first
10 minutes the narration shifts from the
future to remembering the past and you
meet harry selden and his adopted son
rach 35 years prior at the imperial
library on the empire's capital planet
trantor they're discussing gail's
arrival and then we meet her on her
homeworld of cinex you see her looking
at her prayer stones that she removed
before her journey to trantor to meet
harry these are cultural markers that
every member of the seer's church has in
their cheeks you get the feeling that
her leaving has set her apart from her
people and later learned that math and
science go against their beliefs as you
learn more about her background you find
out that the waters are rising on synax
threatening their way of life and the
people have turned to faith for answers
this led to the universities being
burned down and a purge of intellectuals
gail taught herself math hoping to help
save her people she won a contest by
solving a problem called the abraxas
conjecture which no one had been able to
figure out for over 500 years after that
she gets offered a job by harry selden
and says goodbye to her parents before
leaving synax for good she gets
transported to a jump ship which is our
introduction to the hyperspatial travel
that made it possible for humans to
settle on habitable planets throughout
the galaxy she meets a man named gerald
just before they're put to sleep for the
jump he turns out to be an agent of the
empire that was sent to spy on her he
tells her they have to be put to sleep
because sometimes it can feel like your
mind and body are taking different trips
they have to be secured in these pods
because the artificial gravity has to be
turned off so they can navigate the jump
for some reason gail wakes up while
they're in transit which is strange and
she's immediately sedated by one of the
spacers working on the ship if you're
curious as to what these spacers are
i'll come back to them after the recap
when she arrives on trantor she takes
the star bridge down to the planet and
there's a lot of world building in the
details while she's on her way to meet
rach who takes her to harry you learn
that billions of people live below the
surface on 100 subterranean levels where
they never see the sun or the stars
trantor is an ecumenopolis the entire
planet is encompassed by the city as the
surface became completely developed they
started to build down and then they do
things like projecting skies overhead on
the lower levels to make it look more
natural
harry asked her some questions about how
she solved the problem in an effort to
get to know her and then he drops it on
her that they're going to be arrested
tomorrow when she asks why he questions
if she's familiar with his work on
psycho history he says it's the destiny
of the human race expressed in numbers
when she hears this she asks if they're
worried that he can predict the future
and he says that they're worried that
people believe he can and they don't
like the future he predicts he tells her
that trantor is going to be destroyed
and the empire will fall when he shows
her the prime radiant which is the
visual representation of his equations
she realizes that they believe she's the
only one that can prove him wrong harry
agrees that that's true if he was wrong
she would be able to prove it but he's
not this is all bad news for her she
left home where she would have been
arrested only to find out she'll face
the same thing on trantor on the way out
she asks rates to take her to a seer
church and the priest knows who she is
and he isn't a fan of selden's
prophecies either
you also meet the genetic dynasty of
dawn day and dusk they're all clones of
emperor cleon the first who have been
ruling for four centuries you see that
they do consider selden as a threat and
also that they can be cruel when day
kills a man who's been working for him
for over 60 years just for being in
possession of something that harry wrote
the three versions of the same person at
three different ages have complete
control of the empire day sits on the
middle throne as the leader until dawn
grows old enough to take his place dusk
advises his younger selves and the cycle
continues edo demersel is their first
minister and appears to assist in
managing everything on top of going
after harry and gail the cleons are
dealing with a dispute over resources
between two planets that hate each other
anacrion and thespis because some agents
of the empire were killed in the dispute
they've been summoned to answer for that
and to try to avoid an all-out war gail
and harry are arrested and their trial
is public regular citizens are able to
watch it with the cleons watching very
closely harry explains that psycho
history is a predictive model designed
to forecast the behavior of very large
populations when questioned as to what
it says about the empire he says it's
going to fall in 500 years or possibly
sooner they accuse him of trying to
undermine an empire that's existed for
12 000 years and he pleads that he's not
a revolutionary it's just what the math
says he claims the collapse is too far
along it can't be stopped but they can
shorten the 30 000 years of barbarism
that's going to follow it they can cut
that to just 1 000 years he can't prove
any of this his predictions can't be
checked because no one really
understands the math except for gail so
after the first day of questioning
gerald comes back and gives gal the
prime radiant he tells her that she has
to disavow harry and say that his math
is wrong and if for some reason the
equations turn out to be correct the
empire will deal with that they'll fix
the problems without terrifying
trillions of people
he gives her an ultimatum either she
says that harry's wrong and he dies and
if she doesn't she dies when she takes
the prime radiant back to her room she's
able to activate it and see the
equations in court the next day harry is
asked directly how he would shorten the
period of chaos his plan is to create an
encyclopedia galactica essentially
collect all of mankind's knowledge and
then print it and distribute it after
the fall a new empire will rise from the
ashes and this will serve as a
foundation of knowledge for them to
build upon when they call gail to
testify she goes against the empire
verifying that selden's math is correct
and she confirms that the empire is
dying as they're leaving the courtroom
she senses that something's wrong with
the starbridge and tells harry about it
then it cuts to two simultaneous suicide
bomber attacks on the bridge and the
platform you see it kill everyone there
as it falls out of orbit to wrap around
the planet tearing 50 levels down
there's a hundred million people dead
and there's a fear that the outer
reaches may be in rebellion
rage gives gayle a chance to give harry
up but she refuses and they're taken in
front of the emperor harry's work has
convinced him that things are going to
get worse so the starbridge attack isn't
a surprise he doesn't say that he
predicted that that would happen
specifically but it sounds like he knew
something would and he explains he can't
figure out who did it because he can't
predict individual's actions and then
when asked if the fall can be slowed
down he says yes they need to end the
genetic dynasty dust gets angry about
that saying that the dynasty stopped the
wars harry stands by it he says that
change will help things but there's no
movement on either side when they ask
why they shouldn't just kill harry gal
steps in and says that it would actually
speed things up that she saw that when
she looked at the equations she says
that harry's hope and if they kill hope
then the people will kill them when
they're alone together gail realizes the
contest was set up to find someone that
could understand selden's equations he
just reached out and got to her before
they did they're brought back in and
told that the decision is to let them
continue their work on psycho history
but not on trantor they're being allowed
to travel by slow ship to an uninhabited
planet called terminus which of course
we saw at the beginning without a jump
ship the trip will take them years
they've been exiled and if psycho
history turns out to be fraudulent then
the foundation will just be allowed to
wither and if it's useful the empire can
just co-opt it for themselves terminus
is on the periphery and it neighbors the
two kingdoms that are apparently behind
the starbridge attack on the way out
gail begins to realize that exile was
always harry's plan he says the planet
is perfect for what they need to do and
that's the twist is that even though he
was gambling to a certain extent on
these things everything had been planned
in advance and it did work out how he
expected he tells her you came here to
save your world why not think bigger
save the galaxy and then it cuts to
terminus 35 years later the narration
picks back up saying no one could
approach the vault except for an outlier
like salve or harden gail says she
always wondered if when harry was
formulating the plan did he realize the
galaxy's fate would rest on what she
found inside she thinks he did and
thinks that's what he feared the most
in the beginning of episode 2 the cleon
still can't figure out who contracted
the people who were responsible for the
starbridge attack demarzel's looking
into it she goes to a biohacking place
at one point and without anything else
to go on brother day still just kind of
wants to kill harry but demarzel won't
let it happen because she knows there's
nothing to connect him to the crime both
enacrion and thespis deny being involved
and that seems like they're probably
telling the truth they hate each other
so it doesn't really make sense for them
to collaborate on the attack we see that
dusk is getting old and we see that
there's a natural tension that exists
between him and day we can imagine that
this probably always happens and he goes
to see the seer priest at the church
that gail went to where he sees the
destruction of what happened firsthand
he's trying to find out if gail is a
seer based on the weird stuff we've seen
around her it's an interesting question
while they're there demerizel gets hit
by a falling rock and then later we see
brother dawn watching as she repairs
herself and that she's revealed to be a
robot and you may have noticed that
there aren't any real robots around in
trantor as it is brother dawn says that
all of her kind had died and she
corrects him saying they didn't die they
were destroyed by his kind so she does
her best to act like a human and at this
point it's not really clear how well her
true identity is covered up after
talking to the anacrion and the thespin
they have in their custody dust decides
that mercy is the right way to go
brother day doesn't listen and decides
to make an example of the outer worlds
he sends ships to attack the planet and
then executes the members of the
delegation who came to trantor but
leaves the two leaders alive to go back
and tell their people how they failed
there's a teaching moment here for
brother dawn demerizel tells him it
won't always be like this when he asks
exactly how often do they choose to do
things like this she just says you
always do on the slow ship gail and
rachel started a relationship that's
getting serious and you learn that
there's four months and four years left
of the trip you see that everyone's
getting prepared to live they're
learning new skills you meet some of the
new characters that would still be
around in salvor's timeline if nothing
else the colonists look serious they
believe that the empire is going to fall
and what they're doing is going to be
very important with the foundation to
preserve knowledge and rebuild the
civilization there's a side story here
about a pregnancy that gayle's involved
in it appears that women who get
pregnant opt to preserve that until
after they make it to terminus so it
makes you wonder if rach and gayle won't
be the parents of somebody who turns out
to be important and i guess it should be
noted that salvor hardin isn't born yet
we do see the two characters here that
are cast to play her parents when
they're much younger than what they'll
be in that timeline but otherwise i
don't see how this pregnancy thing is
really essential if it's not going to
pay off later either way they're trying
to hide the relationship from harry and
in his interactions you can see that he
realizes that the foundation is going to
be successful at least the plan is fully
in motion but that his time with it is
coming to an end the calculations show
that it's going to be a tough road for
the people who are left behind something
like a mortality rate of 34.2 percent
after five years on terminus although he
says this is trending downward so their
training is working in their
conversation there's also a mention of
the robot wars and the hanging of ai
sympathizers in an orchard in the
imperial gardens this all refers back to
what demarzel was telling brother dawn
about her kind being destroyed by humans
the episode comes to an end as gail's
following her normal routine she's in
the pool swimming and then she gets a
feeling that something's wrong and
decides to leave she goes looking for
rach and can't find him and that leads
her to harry's room where she sees rach
stabbing him and taking his life we also
see that rach takes something from
behind his ear before he goes after her
and then he puts her in a pod throwing
his knife inside telling her that he
loves her and then he launches it the
pod seems to be programmed and it looks
like she's probably being put to sleep
for a period of time it's definitely not
clear if her interrupting what happened
in harry's room is why she's on the pod
as all of her interactions with harry
earlier made it seem like he was
grooming her to be the leader on
terminus he even sent her to that
meeting to sit in in his place it's
definitely possible that she interrupted
because of that feeling she had and then
rach had to change his plan which we're
gonna have to wait and see what was
really going on with that because all of
his interactions with harry portrayed
them having a close and loving
relationship there was the awkward
interaction at dinner we hadn't seen
anything like that between them before
everything we'd seen from rach was that
he was concerned even though he might
not have been a hundred percent positive
that harry was right and there
definitely are seeds planted there where
it could go the other way gail telling
him that the math wasn't complete and
it's a pretty good cliffhanger when you
think about it like that so i'm excited
to see where it goes in the next episode
so to wrap it all up harry used psycho
history to forecast the fall of the
empire he believes what the math is
telling him and knows that the cleons
will never give up their power willingly
by solving abraxas when no one else
could gail is considered the best person
to check if his work is correct she gets
pulled into the situation she decides to
go against the empire and this all leads
to all these people on the slow ship
being exiled to terminus to create the
foundation there's quite a few mysteries
to think about first and foremost who's
really behind the attack on the
starbridge it definitely doesn't seem
like the people that are being punished
are the ones who did it which means
there could be blowback from that but
also that there could be another force
in play gail has plenty of mysteries
around her too this idea that she senses
things why did she wake up during the
jump where did she go at the end is she
hibernating and for how long what was
the significance of the zygote scene is
part of the reason that they gender
swapped this character because she's
going to have descendants on terminus
why did rach kill harry that feels like
it was part of the plan rather than some
murderous rage but then how did gail
walking in change things what was the
device he took from behind harry's ear
what's going on with the vault how did
it get there because it seems beyond
harry's natural skill set although he
did have a lot of people working for him
and what's going on with the cleons
having a robot they kept demarzelle
mostly in the background in these two
episodes but even if you don't know
anything about the books i'm sure she's
starting to pique your interest as for a
review it looks really fantastic and
that's super promising for it being
around long enough to turn into
something that will be remembered as a
great tv series sci-fi of this scale is
tough to pull off and there's a balance
with all the necessary world building
you have to do in the beginning to set
the stage with it not being overwhelming
and finding something compelling
something watchable to hook viewers in
in this case you're also working with
the book series that people won't want
to see changed in any way for that
reason i tried to watch this without
comparing it too much to the books since
in my opinion there are some obvious
problems in making an overly faithful
adaptation for tv generally i think the
creators took most of those things into
account and came up with clever
solutions it turns out though that the
trick is to make those changes where
they don't disrupt the big ideas behind
the original every change you make
affects the rest of the story and only
time will tell if they'll be able to
pull that off the solution to make the
emperor's clones is a novel idea and you
can't go wrong with lee pace and i
especially like the idea that even
though they're all copies of the same
man they still want to distinguish
themselves and we're just gonna have to
see where they take the genetic dynasty
as there's really no reason to think
they're gonna give up power or that the
people on terminus would be able to
undermine that anytime soon a lot of
what i liked about the books is the way
that people who don't understand the
plan they're following react to that and
then the bigger ideas about what is the
right way to create a new civilization
personalities present themselves at the
right time but none of the characters
are important in the long run beyond the
situation that they're faced with so it
comes off a little strange when you
introduce ideas around characters being
special changing it up isn't necessarily
bad but hopefully it won't take away
from the original story's appeal after
watching the first two episodes i'm
dazzled by the visuals and most of the
performances and feel optimistic overall
i think it was a good start and even if
everything doesn't work out in the first
season it's comforting knowing that
there's still a lot of good story they
can draw from in the future one thing
that stands out as a big question mark
for me is demarzel being involved in
killing based on the three laws of
robotics i know there's the xeroth law
but they're gonna have to address this
at some point i mentioned that i would
come back to the spacers it's not clear
what they're doing with them here they
almost look like robots in asimov's
robot series spacers are people who
decided that they wanted to live away
from earth after hyperspatial travel
became common this is a real
simplification but humans became divided
into two groups the people on earth at
that time they were sort of anti-robot
they wanted things to stay more or less
the same and the spacers wanted to go
out and colonize and become something
different i also mentioned how gayle's
narration was from the perspective of
the future in the books we had excerpts
from the encyclopedia galactica the same
book that they go to terminus to create
so those give historical accounts from a
time later about what's going on in the
actual timeline so that's a neat nod the
way that they did that with the obvious
change that some of these characters are
going to be around longer than just the
period of time where they're introduced
they kept harry seldon mostly the same
his characterization what he was trying
to do that all sticks pretty close to
the books where you see the differences
and it would take a whole other video to
actually point all those out is where
they're giving these other characters a
story in an effort to try to get us to
care about them and i think that's a
good place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you think if you
want to include things about the book
series please mark those we don't want
to spoil it for everyone else let me
know any theories that you came up with
how you think things might play out
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon